[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with Zoe Williams columnist at the
guardian and writer Benedict Spence
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now the guardian
leads on the Prime Minister considering
a one-off cash offer for nurses head of
ministers meeting with health unions
tomorrow
not a spare in the world reads the front
page of the Metro as they picture a
smiling King in Sandringham
The Daily Mail reports on Prince Harry's
television interview accusing his family
in the pain and suffering inflicted on
his wife
the financial times shared light on U.S
and Japanese forces preparing for a
possible conflict with China
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us and we are joined tonight by
writer Benedict Spence and Zoe Williams
columnist at the guardian welcome to
both of you let's start with the Metro
and their headline there not a spare in
the world Charles greets uh crowd as
Harry hits out on TV Benedict you take
us into this Festival
yes this is the uh well this is the news
I'm not sure if it is news so much that
uh uh the King has put on a brave face
uh today whilst meeting people uh at
Sandringham uh in sort of uh in
preparation if you like for the
documentary over the interview rather
that's come out this evening and that
everybody seems to have watched
everybody's talking about on Twitter uh
Prince Harry talking about everything
that's going on with his new book
um I think it's uh perhaps wise that the
king simply smiled and was polite to
people because it seems that every time
a royal does an interview it seems to
lower the Public's estimations of them
so you know I I leave it up to other
people to read the front pages and look
at the document uh the interviewer they
have but um it's it continues the the
spiral of rather unedifying uh headlines
that are coming out about this book
about what uh Harry has to say about uh
members of the royal family who I think
are very wisely keeping stum about all
of this
um I'm I yeah I'd be curious to know
what the reception is broadly from
people who I know who've uh read or
watched whatever it is Harry has to say
the response is not positive but there
is always that question isn't there is
this really for the UK can for UK
consumption is this in fact meant for
the audience across the pond in the
United States uh that is of course where
he stands to make most of his money that
is where I think he's a lot more popular
um so you know we wait to see whether or
not that this uh this interview will be
a success whether or not this book will
be a success although I'm sure that
they'll have many eyes on both yes sir
many more Revelations are coming to the
four Zoe but what is uh unlikely to
happen is that there will be any uh
response from the palace
well yeah that's why I think this
headline was a bit called in really
because when you know King Charles has
spent his entire life smiling through
events like in what possible world is he
going to do anything other than arrive
in front of a crowd and smile I don't
think it really tells you anything about
his state of mind and I don't think it
really tells you anything about his you
know hunch around Harry's book and the
revelations in it
um
I'm not wild about the word play either
because it doesn't is is not completely
obvious what they're talking about so
yeah I don't think this is I don't think
this is a brilliant capsule of what's
going on in the royal family but I doubt
we're going to get that you know there
isn't any plausible response from the
the firm as it were and Harry is
obviously determined to tell everybody
absolutely everything yeah so are we
read in the Daily Mail uh Benedict um
his quote or we believe a direct quote
from Harry my family helped to drive out
Megan
um just on the subject of King Charles I
think if anybody wanted to get a quote
from him on anything he'd be better off
talking to him about Homeopathy or wool
then you wouldn't be able to get him
shut up but you know on this sort of
subject I doubt you're going to get
anything at all
um I'm more than prepared to believe
that Megan had a very difficult time uh
when she arrived in that family it is
famously not not an easy set to
penetrate
um but I go back to what I just said
which is that every time a member of the
royal family and it does tend to be
members of the royal family who are on
the out uh give these kind of interviews
uh they in fact make their own public
perception are a lot worse and I think
actually that
um Megan has done that with her with her
interviews uh with Oprah Winfrey and her
podcast series I don't think actually
certainly in the UK at least I don't
think she has improved uh the image and
you know many people who might have been
prepared to say yes we're prepared to
believe that it's very difficult and
that you were sort of um put in put in
rather a difficult spot and then also
have to listen to sort of how she
conducts herself what she says about
other people people and think but
perhaps you didn't make it entirely easy
for yourself and I think that that is
ultimately what we need to take from
this one side will speak a lot one side
will say very little except what they
leak to the Press but you do need to
remember that there are two sides and
ultimately it is unlikely that anybody
has covered themselves in glory
do you think that the public here are
more likely to be uh
Megan now as more Revelations are coming
out
I think me and Benedict must just run in
really different circles because I of
course anybody who doesn't have a huge
amount of sympathy for Megan for you
know the racism that is plainly legible
in the British mainstream media and the
obvious relationship between the royal
family and that media which as he says
in the interview did enable that you
know what was this if essentially a
torrent of hate speech by the end on
social media and a huge amount of
innuendo and insinuation in the Tabloid
media so I don't I mean everybody I know
thinks this is a real stain on British
Society the way she was treated
um and I don't think that it's nothing
the revelations about Prince William
attacking his brother physically on more
than one occasion I don't think I don't
think that will pass unnoticed I don't
think it is normal everybody you know
there's been an absolute pile on in in
the kind of center-right press of like
sibling rivalry happens to everyone not
in your mid-30s it doesn't I mean I
don't know very many people whose
brothers have crashed under the floor
into a dog bowl in their mid-30s it
seems like
whether the other side keeps silent and
just operates with leaks or actually
says anything I don't think they're
going to come away unscathed from that
let's move away from the royal family
and Prince Harry's Revelations to the
guardian uh Benedict and this to do with
the the NHS the Prime Minister we read
is looking at a one offer one off cash
offer to end the nurses Striker and this
is uh further negotiations to take place
starting tomorrow
yes and I think ultimately you know it's
it's the first signs of the government
beginning to shift as I think everybody
suspected that they would have to you
cannot be in a situation where nurses
are going on strike because they've been
systematically underpaid for over a
decade
um and just sort of throw up your hands
and go oh well those them nurses they're
just being a bit greedy when everybody's
trying to pull their socks up I do think
that
um you know it's it's unfortunate for
the nurses that they've sort of gone on
strike at the same time as other perhaps
less popular unions but actually I don't
think any public sympathy has wavered
from the nurses from the ambulance
drivers from NHS Strath in general and
especially after the government set the
precedent of coming and doing a deal
with the criminal Bar Association uh
because you know court cases are in some
cases three years behind schedule
um you know I think that there was
always going to have to be some movement
because the government has shown that on
significant issues such as this it has
no choice now obviously I think this is
just the opening Gambit they're saying
it'll be a one-off payment and perhaps
talking about increasing pay down the
line in return for dropping demands for
paid be happening this year and
reopening uh the the previous wage
settlement whether or not it'll be
accepted I'm not sure that it will I
think that the nurses will correctly see
that as a government beginning to cave
in Under Pressure recognizing that it
cannot it cannot be the government that
finally oversees the NHS collapsing
because it refused to pay nurses on
Wards uh what they needed to live on uh
so I think that this is uh this is just
the first bit of the government moving I
think that the deal will be better than
what's currently being offered so would
you believe that this is the beginning
of a breakthrough
well I mean I would never call it a
breakthrough because it's such a
disaster the whole thing you know it's
like it's absolutely catastrophic for
zunak the way he goes into things saying
no I'm absolutely unbudgetable on this I
cannot move I will not move and then two
weeks later three weeks later he moves
it just makes him look ridiculous and it
damages his position or does it show
that he's listening
show he's listening at all because the
situation hasn't changed you know the
nurse exactly as Benedict said nurses
have been struggling with stagnant wages
for a decade and that you know they were
everything that isn't 10 is an effective
real terms wage cart they wanted 19 all
of these facts are on the table from the
very beginning of the dispute and
there's nothing has really changed for
suit Knack except that he's run out of
Road and he didn't think it through to
begin with so I think he's looking like
a prime minister who doesn't think
things through and I think he's and I
think that's this is by no means the
first time that's happened the other
thing is you know there are two parallel
things going on with nurses and their
conditions there are other kind there's
the pay dispute in one column which is
in which their case is extremely strong
but there's also the chronic under
underfunding as a result of not being
able to recruit nurses and therefore
their conditions at work are absolutely
appalling you know they're working in
shifts with like six members of Staff
missing at any one time they're
overworked they're doing three hours
just to keep their colleagues afloat
they're really really in crisis from a
kind of long-term failure to recruit
which again has its roots in Pay but not
this immediate pay battle now a one-off
payment for a winter crisis is not going
to solve that and everybody knows that
it's not going to solve it so it
unless the government comes up with
something much much better longer term
more coherent than these kind of running
just to catch up sticking plaster
approaches okay I don't think they're
going to get any political capital from
it Zoe and Benedict thanks so much for
the moment we're going to take a break
coming out per their story on the front
of the Daily Telegraph which reads NHS
to send 3 000 patients stuck in hospital
to Care Homes within a week that and
more when we come back
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
previews to with me writer Benedict
Spence and Zoe Williams columnist at the
guardian we'll still continue talking
about the NHS and one of the solutions
is that we read in the Daily Telegraph 3
000 patients that are stuck in in
hospital are necessarily are going to be
sent to Care Homes and that should take
place within a week we read Benedict
yes and I think that that's it's an
incredibly important part of dealing
with the multitude of Crisis that the
NHL NHS has
um uh the subject of bed blocking of
course people who are fit to be sent
into Care Homes but there just isn't the
capacity for them or they're you know
what are needing to be sent to their
homes and that there isn't the resources
for them there
um yeah and that was you know before we
had the strikes that was the cause of a
lot of the delays and the cues in a e
and of course you know along before we
had the strikes uh they would talk about
um sort of 40
um of of ambulances being forced to wait
because hospitals just didn't have the
capacity and a large amount of that was
because of people especially elderly and
vulnerable people uh not able to be
discharged because there wasn't the
capacity and this is of course a
knock-on effect this is of course a
knock-on issue uh part of the NHS uh
crisis and it sort of shows how all of
these things are interrelated you can
spend an awful lot of money
um on nurses conditions and pay for
ambulance drivers and capacity and that
still doesn't actually solve the care
issue which you know which has sort of
gone on to the radar until
um the last few years in this country
but has really crept up on us and this
is another aspect of where this country
is headed with an aging population you
can spend as much money on the NHS and
it's going to continue to struggle if
this area is not addressed because the
population is aging it'll always be
playing catch-up and that is another
area that we are I I don't see uh
without building more capacity without
investing more in care and capacity
without designating more resources to
that sector I don't see long-term how we
solve that it is again as though it was
alluding to in the first half
um of the of the press preview this is a
lack of long-term planning not just
about finding short-term Solutions and
ultimately it's a government that's been
in power for 10 12 years this is
something that should have been handled
a long time ago and now we have a new
prime minister in the job for a matter
of months sort of scrambling scrambling
to find a solution to it Zoe is this a
sticking plaster or is this um the
future
I mean it's really interesting to talk
about this as a problem that's crept up
on the government because this was what
Theresa May came undone on in the 2017
election was how promised to sort out
social care with what then came to be
known as the dementia tax then the the
idea to put up National Insurance
obviously
of in stock because it was going to
really really hit families who were
already really struggling so they've
been it it would be one thing if any
government in the past 12 years had had
a plan and actually carried it out and
then there was something real to discuss
you know who's winning and who's losing
from this way of funding the care model
that would be one thing but what we've
got instead is a government that comes
up with you know sometimes quite large
schemes sometimes quite random schemes
but they never happen because no because
we haven't had a strong enough or
competent enough or United enough
conservative party for so long that none
of this can happen now this the soonat
scheme to put people in Care Homes
you've got to remember the problem with
Care Homes which is that there was a
huge amount of private Equity takeover
more than more than 10 years ago and the
Care Homes themselves are now paying
rent to the property developer the
property arm of the company that owns
them so this is got a very complicated
Financial Arrangement which makes most
of these Care Homes really really on the
edge financially on the edge to the that
the staff are kind of buying the
biscuits for them so I just want to
bring in um your paper actually the the
guardian on this story because we're
running out of time and uh the storming
of Congress in Brazil that we've seen
tonight uh Benedict the picture on the
front page of the guardian and these are
supporters of Jaya bolsonaro refusing
the results of the election
yeah um almost two years to the day in
fact since um since the U.S capital was
stormed by supporters of former
president Donald Trump it's almost
spooky
um I think why I mean obviously this is
very serious you can't have a situation
where you know thousands of people are
storming the government buildings and
you know apparently doing so without
police intervening or not intervening in
the manner they should have done as
happened uh at the U.S Capitol to a
degree but again it's a situation of an
election of a very large you know a very
large country quite a significant
country uh between two wings that are
not actually particularly particularly
popular and it being quite narrow the
results and I think that this marks the
beginning of a lot of problems actually
for Brazil I know a lot of people were
thinking after Jay abolsonaro lost that
there would be the return of some
semblance of normality to Brazil and I
don't think that that's the case at all
the majority of elected officials in
Brazil uh actually are if not pro
bolsonaro then a lot more sympathetic to
him than the artists
that is worrying for the future of
Brazil indeed Benedict and Zoe thank you
so much for taking us through the papers
we'll see you in the next hour